dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with dr carol jonaife
today we have a selection of learning
based techniques that can generate
images of photorealistic human faces for
people
that don't exist these techniques have
come a long way over the last few years
so much so that we can now even edit
these images to our lacking
by for instance putting a smile on their
faces
making them older or younger adding or
removing a beard
and more however most of these
techniques are still
lacking in two things one is diversity
of outputs
and two generalization to multiple
domains
typically the ones that work on multiple
domains don't perform too well
on most of them this new technique is
called stargand2
and addresses both of these issues let's
start with the humans
in the footage here you see a lot of
interpolation between test subjects
which means that we start out from a
source person
and generate images that morph them into
the target subjects
not in any way but in a way that
all of the intermediate images are
believable
in these results many attributes from
the input subject
such as pose nose type mouth shape
and position are also reflected on the
output
i like how the motion of the images on
the left reflects
the state of the interpolation as this
slowly takes place
we can witness how the reference person
grows out a beard
but we are not nearly done yet we noted
that another great advantage of this
technique
is that it works for multiple domains
and this means of course
none other than us looking at cats
morphing into dogs
and other animals in these cases i see
that the algorithm picks up the gaze
direction
so this generalizes to even animals
that's great what is even more great is
that the face shape
of the tiger appears to have been
translated to the photo of this cat
and if we have a bigger cat as an input
the output
will also give us this lovely and a
little plump creature
and look here the cat in the input
is occluded in this target image but
that is not translated to the output
image
the ai knows that this is not part of
the cat
but an occlusion imagine what it would
take to prepare
a handcrafted algorithm to distinguish
these features
my goodness and now onto dogs
what is really cool is that in this case
bendy ears have their own meaning
and we get several versions of the same
dog breed with
or without them and it can handle
a variety of other animals too i could
look at these
all day and now to understand why this
works so well
we first have to understand what a
latent space is
here you see an example of a latent
space that was created to be able to
browse
through fonts and even generate new ones
this method essentially tries to look at
a bunch of already existing fonts
and tries to boil them down into the
essence of what makes them different
it is a simpler often incomplete but
more manageable representation for a
given domain
this domain can be almost anything for
instance you see
another technique that does something
similar with material models
now the key difference in this new work
compared to previous techniques
is that it creates not one latent space
but
several of these latent spaces for
different domains
as a result it can not only generate
images in all of these domains but can
also
translate different features for
instance ears
eyes noses from a cat to a dog
or a cheetah in a way that makes sense
and the results look like absolute
witchcraft
now since the look on this cheetah's
face indicates that it has had enough of
this video
just one more example before we go as a
possible failure case
have a look at the ears of this cat it
seems to be in a peculiar
midway land between a pointy and a bent
ear
but it doesn't quite look like any of
them what do you think
maybe some of you cat people can weigh
in on this let me know in the comments
what you see here is an instrumentation
of this exact paper we have talked about
which was made by weights and biases i
think
organizing these experiments really
showcases the usability of their system
weights and biases provides tools to
track your experiments
in your deep learning projects their
system is designed to save you a ton of
time
and money and it is actively used in
projects at prestigious labs
such as open ai toyota research github
and more and the best part is that if
you have an open source
academic or personal project you can use
their tools for free
it really is as good as it gets make
sure to visit them through wnb.com
papers or click the link in the video
description to start tracking your
experiments
in 5 minutes our thanks to weights and
biases for their long-standing support
and for helping us make better videos
for you thanks for watching and for your
generous support
and i see you next time